I think in general terms I think it's  less about stuff like that I just think  it's more that large businesses the  elite have really significant lobbying  power and donation power and you know  their businesses can donate and super  Pacs can donate you know if you think  about you know our GDP and our success  almost all of it comes from small  business because small business you guys  know this you're a small business you  hire people you know you're always  growing you're thinking about how do I  do more how do I get bigger large  business thinks about efficiency  offshoring saving money and so there's  nobody that represents the average  American the small business owner  there's nobody that is truly putting  money time lobbying efforts into that  and so you know you end up with people  that are that only care about you know  significant interests